nous allons recevoir maintenant Oximo
Puccino Oxmo Puccino hein Oxmo je me
trompe mais c'est c'est l'heure tardive
qui fait ça hein
bon et on est on est toujours content
parce que quand quand on vous reçoit ou
quand on vous écoute c'est que quelque
chose se passe sur la scène hiphop
finalement je déteste l'expression je la
déteste mais vous êtes plutôt une valeur
sûre et je vous apprécie plus encore
parce que vous dites avec la musique on
refait le monde et ça ça vous va très
bien on vous écoute dans votre dans un
extrait de votre nouvel album cactus de
sibéry et vous allez nous interpréter
black
d'perado Oxmo
Puccino c'est le black
d'esperado TJ
cream le black
d'esperado
j'allais entamer la 5è manche avec
ma apparaisse dans ma TV ce qui signifie
l' est grave magnifique béb et je
reviens on va à la plage j'ai mon masque
maetteot chance
je r franç fa par une mauvaise chanson€
personne ne la cherche un H prévenu pas
t'inquiète j'ai
l'habitude toujours prprs
toi
quelques joursquis que
je suscepti j'auris pensétin injur
mis r Fran derrière porte si je voulais
allerait passer par son cor en G
prononce un je de Lang s que ça va je
suis tropiveuche en
finesseance va dans les coutes je la par
le coup je montre ces monsieurs me
disent trempzle dans quand j'entends non
la CL juste comme
désqubr jours à
VI
je au
secours hors caméra
depuisopéino rembourser rembourser
rembourser rembours voilà dans la S
atmosphère GL rap français bayonnet par
terre fragonie un public déçu me ser
plus qu'un couplet dans mon chargeur
dites-moi comment tenir un concert un
dernier regard au rap français je m
lance à l'avant la avant la VO en l'air
chaque mot doit toucher sa cible c'est
ma vocale en traverse même le trapzist
FL élastique combinaison consonne des
phrases con qui sonn appelle-moi aussi
l'astuce qui se passe tu penses pas FR
en personne qui donne ça il a mal au
pied il boite il dans sa cloche on
remcie qui mais où est le black il s'est
absenté informé dans l'instant d
paraître qu' ture DJ CRE à la r
soir mais ça c'est une autre histoire
pour Black
d'esperadoour blag d' rgle tout camé
depuisop op
Oxmo Puccino
ouais ouais